79% - 79.1 - 58 and one-tenth and I
encourage you to pause this video and
try to try to compute this expression on
your own well the thing that jumps out
at you is that these are in different
these are in different formats this is a
percentage of different representations
as a percentage this is a decimal this
is a mixed number and so it makes sense
of it it's probably a good idea to get
them all in the same format and it seems
like we could get all of these into a
decimal format pretty easily so let's go
that way
so 79% that literally means 79 per
hundred as if you wanted to write as a
fraction would be 79 over 100 but if you
wanted to write as a decimal it's 79
hundredths which could be zero or we
would write it down as zero point seven
nine now 779 point one is already
written as a as a decimal so we'll just
write again so - seventy nine point one
and then 58 and 1/10
well 1/10 is the same thing as point one
so you could view this as 58 well it and
literally as 1/10 so it's minus 58 and
1/10 or you could view this as 58 point
one so now they're all in the same
format let's actually do the computation
now the first thing that jumps out at
you is you have a fairly small number
here small positive number it's it's
it's less than 1 and you're subtracting
fairly large numbers right over here so
your whole answer is going to be
negative and to make sense of this a
little bit what I'm going to do is I'm
going to factor out a negative sign and
that'll make the computation at least in
my brain it's going to make it a little
bit easier so if we factor out a
negative sign this becomes so we're
going to factor it out actually let me
just do it this way so we could if we
factor out a negative sign then this
will become negative this would be
positive and this is this would be
positive and just to verify this imagine
this distributing this negative sign or
if this was a negative one negative one
times this is positive negative one
times this is negative negative one
times this is negative so these these
two expressions are the exact same thing
and the reason why I did that is now
we'll do the more natural thing if we
will add these two numbers we'll get a
positive number a larger positive number
then what we're going to subtract from
it right over here so we could kind of
use our traditional methods and we
can't forget about this negative out
here so let's first do that let's add
seventy nine point one plus fifty eight
point one so seventy nine point one plus
fifty eight point one so 1/10 plus 1/10
is two tenths 9 Plus 8 is 17 so that's
seven ones and one 10 so one 10 plus 7
tens is going to give us two eight tens
plus five tens gets us to 13 tens or 130
so we have one hundred thirty seven
point two is this part right over here
so one hundred let me write this down so
we have one hundred thirty seven point
two and then from that we can adding a
negative zero point seven nine as the
equivalent of subtracting zero point
seven nine so let's do that let's
subtract zero point seven nine making a
point to align our decimal points so
that we're subtracting the right place
from the right place and now let's do
our subtraction so right now we're
subtracting 9 from nothing we could
write a zero right over here but we
still face an issue in the hundreds
place we're also subtracting a 7/10 from
two tenths so that we're going to have
to regroup a little bit in the numerator
in order to subtract or lose at least in
order to subtract using the the most
traditional technique so let's take a
tenth from the two so it's only one
tenth now and give it to the hundreds so
one tenth is ten hundredths so we could
subtract that ten hundredths minus nine
hundredths is one hundredth now in the
tenths place we don't have enough up
here so let's take one from the ones
place so that becomes a six one is 10
tens so now we have eleven 11 10 11 10
11 minus seven is for better decimal
place six minus zero is six and then we
got our 13 all right just like that so
when I computed all of this inside the
parenthesis so outside the parenthesis I
still have the negative sign when I
computed all of this inside the
parenthesis I got 136 0.41 and then we
can't forget about the negative sign out
here so this whole thing computes to
negative 136 point four
or one